[Music]
you look like you put your whole life
force into this one moment of the film
it's true it is it is and that was a
whole idea you know in Greek mythology
Hercules mythology the I am Hercules
when Hercules finally accepts his fate
of being the son of Zeus he that's when
he gets all of his powers as a demigod
so it was an iconic it's an iconic
moment in the mythology iconic moment in
the movie and I wanted to put everything
I had in it so I had the prop department
make sure that the chains were real and
the steel was real and I couldn't break
it and then just with everything because
it's the moment of the movie right the
movie hinges on this moment so with
everything I could possibly do I just
let it all out I am Hercule then I'm
screaming and all this adrenaline what
happens you know if you're in an
athletic event or anything like that if
you have all this adrenaline you can
actually let it go as you're if you're
fighting or if you're playing football
or whatever but in this case I had no
place to for it to go so it's like you
literally blacked out I did I did yeah
so I blacked out but I was already
chained so I didn't fall on my face and
once I came to it's just so funny
because it's coming after I accept that
I'm a god
it's a great moment like that we're
referring to it as blacked out instead
of fainted it's blacked out oh okay all
right with adrenaline yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wait if Hercules passes out what is
their smelly stuff yeah
ancient smelling stuff and smelling
salts wake up Lord okay we have a clock
here a clip from the movie the clip
[Applause]
whatever says
ever said that on TV never said that
it's a good clip though that clip by Sam
I fight you alright can we show the
click ran yes all right look I made you
back down because you saw what I'm
packing did you see that you actually
got scared for set I did yes yes I
almost faint become the man you were
born to be let it be the death
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right over
that's fantastic man I'm so glad we did
that cliff
[Applause]
you